courtney you can't even keep a nanny kim
shut the [ __ ] up honestly
why would you treat your family like
that it's so
up kim and kourtney kardashian had
another epic sister fight on thursday's
episode of keeping up with the
kardashians
but don't worry it didn't get physical
like the last time
don't ever come at me like that i swear
to god i'll punch you in your face
it all went down after kim approached
her older sister about an incident that
court allegedly had with kim's nanny
after the unnamed employee allegedly
said this
to court's youngest son reign she's like
boy
you're a liar while kim agreed that her
nanny shouldn't have called rayne a liar
as courtney claimed
she said she wasn't going to fire her
over the incident
if you think she works for you that's
totally fine she would never work for me
with what the way she acts
that's totally your choice she will not
ever be around my kids
that's when kim hit below the belt
courtney you can't even keep a nanny
kim shut the [ __ ] up honestly the way
you're talking is wild
it's just so uncomfortable this is
insane
but the sisters smooth things over
pretty fast it was
a whirlwind after court had an emotional
convo with chloe about the fight
all three of the sisters agreed that
they wanted to work on how they talk to
each other
i think that i could have handled it
better and i feel guilty that i
contributed to
this negativity and kim was quick to say
she was sorry
i think just as a family we should
definitely like
work on that i'm happy that kim came
over to talk
i think most of the fights that we have
lately especially the ones with me and
kim
would not get nearly as far if we just
learned to communicate
without all this negativity later on
court chloe and scott disick came up
with a family competition to work toward
their goal
with a negativity jar kinda like a swear
jar where they put money in
anytime they're not being so nice or as
chloe put it
leave it to chloe to tell it like it is
i'm gonna figure it all out i promise
you
it's just being aware every time you do
something or say something that's
negative
put something in this jar where you're
aware okay i'm being
an [ __ ] right now and let's stop
hopefully this will change the tune
of this house so it seems like the
kardashian fam is ready to end their
show
on a high note tune in because you never
know what's going to happen
this season marks the 20th and final
season of keeping up and
in september shortly after the news
broke the show's
executive producer ryan seacrest opened
up about the famous family's decision to
walk away
this was a very very hard decision for
them to make you look back
at 14 years and 20 seasons of a camera
in your life and think about that at
some point you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it but they'll be
back on tv soon
the family inked a major new deal with
hulu
you